a liberal judge has won her race for the
Wisconsin Supreme Court and this gives
liberals control of the Wisconsin
Supreme Court for the first time in 15
years now of course we are going to be
talking about the fact that the failed
former president Donald Trump was
arrested but I wanted to start with this
today because some good things did
actually happen yesterday we also got a
progressive mayor in Chicago which we're
going to talk about we'll talk about the
Trump stuff but let's start here this
has been a hugely right-wing Supreme
Court in Wisconsin abortion rights are
in question
gerrymandering related issues executed
by Republicans are a major issue that
may indeed come before the Wisconsin
Supreme Court in the future and so this
is a very good piece of news the New
York Times report liberal wins Wisconsin
court race in Victory for abortion
rights backers Janet pritasowitz
prevailed in the state's highly
consequential contest for the Supreme
Court which will now be likely to
reverse the state's abortion ban huge
and end the use of gerrymandered
legislative Maps this is very very good
news the defeated conservative was
Daniel Kelly
former Wisconsin Supreme Court Justice
who was trying to get his way back onto
the bench with more than 95 percent of
the votes counted by Wednesday morning
this morning judge pertazowitz led by 11
points which is a very big margin of
Victory now there were all these things
about oh well she crushed him no she
didn't she's only up by 11. understand
that in a state like Wisconsin which is
as divided as it is an 11 Point Victory
in this race is quite a walloping quite
frankly I don't know how else to say it
a whole bunch of money was spent on this
race and at the end of the day the
60-year-old pritasowitz is going to now
make this the first liberal Supreme
Court
in 15 years in the state of Wisconsin I
want to play for you a little bit of the
disgusting concession speech from Kelly
this is this is a uh you know it this is
a tantrum sort of concession speech
attacking his opponent take a look at
this brings me no joy to say this
I wish that in a circumstance like this
I would be able to concede to a worthy
opponent whoa
but I do not have a worthy opponent to
which I can concede wow
this was the most deeply deceitful
dishonorable despicable campaign I have
ever seen Run for the courts is he
talking about himself
it was truly beneath contempt anyway so
a very bitter concession speech there
from Daniel Kelly but at the end of the
day we've been talking about this this
is what happens when you exist in a Maga
bubble and you pick candidates based not
on what is actually going on in the
country but based on what you think is
going on based on your tiny little
bubble and we saw this in Kansas when it
came to the abortion vote and they
decided to run an anti-abortion
extremist in Wisconsin and Wisconsin is
more Progressive than Kansas even Kansas
voted to defend abortion rights so it's
not crazy to look at these results and
say yeah that sort of makes sense you
shouldn't have run the anti-abortion nut
um also you know 2020 was rigged isn't
great the same guy Daniel Kelly advised
the state Republican party in crafting
one of those fake elector schemes to try
to get Donald Trump the electoral votes
from Wisconsin rather than Joe Biden we
saw that that costs them a lot and uh
this is this is what happens so when you
look back at the Wisconsin Supreme Court
you see a bunch of very right-wing
decisions during the covet era the right
wing the then right-wing Wisconsin
Supreme Court
struck down the stay-at-home order from
the governor Tony Evers similar orders
all over the country it was just what
was being done they struck that down in
July of 2020 the right-wing Wisconsin
Supreme Court blocked a plan to delay
the primary because of the pandemic
something that was done in other states
it wasn't really like the biggest deal
and then they struck down a mask mandate
as well and again Most states had these
at that point in time eventually they
went away so this is hugely
consequential consequential we are going
to see this decision so first of all
when you when you see a court change
hands uh you don't always know the full
consequences because you don't yet know
what may come before that court but we
know that when it comes to the abortion
ban almost certainly this is a court
that's going to have to deal with that
when you look at uh gerrymandering
almost certainly this is a court that
would deal with that and importantly we
don't yet know what's going to happen in
November of 2024.
if you said well it's Connecticut I
could tell you with certainty this is
not going to be a consequential state in
determining who is the president
Connecticut's just not going to be that
Wisconsin is increasingly a flash point
in the we are going to try to steal it
Narrative of the right and so the
Supreme Court of Wisconsin might
actually play a role in 2024 in ensuring
now that we know who's on the court in
ensuring that the candidate who received
the most votes actually gets the
electoral vote so hugely consequential
great news out of Wisconsin also great
news out of Chicago let's talk about
that next Progressive uh Union organizer
Brandon Johnson let's go Brandon has
been elected mayor of Chicago Illinois
well certainly now the police will be
defunded right no in fact Brandon
Johnson has outlined a very sensible
plan for reforming and continuing to
improve policing in Chicago HuffPost
reports Brandon Johnson Progressive
Union organizer elected mayor of Chicago
Johnson's victory over Centrist Paul
vallis is a major achievement for the
activists left that is absolutely the
case Johnson is described in this
article as a black leftist and former
school teacher
Paul vallis was the former CEO of
Chicago Public Schools this Victory is
being called again by HuffPost one of
the starkest ideological proxy battles
in the annals of recent Municipal
politics and it is a historic
achievement for the activists left
likely to have Ripple effects across the
country okay that's the characterization
by HuffPost there's a lot there it may
be the case it may not be this is super
interesting for a number of different
reasons first of all remember that the
former mayor of Chicago Lori Lightfoot
lost her primary that's interesting in
and of itself sometimes when you see
folks positioned like Lori Lightfoot
lose primaries it's because there's a
Resurgence by the right meaning that
you're going to see some hardcore
conservative or whatever the case may be
Chicago is not a conservative City so
it's not particularly likely but
sometimes when you see incumbents
defeated it's because of a big shift
this is a shift but it is a shift to the
left and it's another reminder that a
lot of these Republicans in different
parts of the country I know Chicago is
its own thing
but it's a warning if you combine this
with the results from Wisconsin two
right Wingers that they need to run and
meet voters where they actually are not
whether they not where they might
wrongly imagine voters to be and it is a
reality in the United States that on
issues on just about every issue most
parts of the country have moved to the
left now that obviously depends on where
you started more conservative areas have
moved to the left but they're still
conservative just less so and more
Progressive areas have moved to the left
and they're becoming more Progressive
the abortion results in Kansas are a
reminder of that so it's going to be
interesting to follow this it's also an
incredible path for Brandon Johnson to
this eventual Victory when he started
before the first round of voting in
Chicago he was polling two percent and
now he got himself to winning the runoff
and now becoming the mayor of Chicago so
he will be judged by the results this is
a victory ideologically for the
progressive left now he actually has to
come in and make things happen of course
Republicans around the country often
love to point to Chicago as the example
of just devastating anti-police uh
politicking and what happens when you
hamper police and crime explodes and gun
violence and all these different things
of course we know how to zoom out
and to take a more fact-based view when
it comes to gun violence in Chicago
despite Chicago's strict gun laws you
drive 40 minutes to Indiana or I think
it's like 60 or 70 minutes to Wisconsin
and all of a sudden it's much easier to
get firearms and you have to account for
that when it comes to oh they want to
defund the police defund the police
almost no one wants to defund the police
sure you can find some activists on the
left that say defund almost everyone
says reform and indeed Brandon Johnson
plans to reform the police and in some
cases from what I've seen him say it
might require actually adding funding in
order to achieve things through new
programs that they want to start so
we're going to watch and see but a big
night for the left a win in Wisconsin a
win in Chicago and yes we also saw the
failed former president Donald Trump
arrested we will talk about that after
the break now that we've gotten to some
of this very very good news
one of our sponsors today is Bon charge
I have always enjoyed dry saunas you get
in there your heart rate is up dilates
the blood vessels can soothe achy joints
and muscles it's relaxing it's just a
great way to remove a little stress Bon
charge is the creator of the infrared
sauna blanket which you can enjoy from
home super easy to set up heats up fast
you don't have to have your head inside
like at a traditional sauna at the gym
nice for meditating or reading getting
work done relaxing I have found it to be
a great way to unwind at the end of a
long day easy to clean Sleek lightweight
design easy to store and comes with a 12
month warranty and of course if you
don't love it returns are super easy but
I think you will love it go to
boncharge.com Pacman and use the code
Pacman 15 for 15 off the link is down
below
the David packman show is an audience
supported program we primarily depend on
you to fund our program if you
appreciate what we do or even if you
don't like it but think it's worthwhile
to have it you can sign up at
joinpakman.com you can use the coupon
code indicted or you can use the coupon
code indicated the way Donald Trump
wrongly spelled indicted in that truth
Central post the other day you'll get
instant access to the bonus show
commercial free audio and video feeds of
the show and you'll get the entire
program every day hours before it is
released publicly on all of our
different platforms sign up at
joinpakman.com coupon code indicted or
indicated your choice the former
president of the United States Donald
Trump was arrested and perp walked
yesterday in New York City police
custody with no handcuffs and reportedly
no mug shot and pleaded guilty sorry
pleaded not guilty what a Freudian slip
pleaded not guilty to 34 different
felonies we will talk about the alleged
crimes we will talk about the potential
penalties we will go to the attorney
post arrest press conference Trump's
Mar-A-Lago speech we're going to cover
everything
but it's important to sit back for a
moment and understand
it was almost surreal yesterday as we
did many many many many many many hours
of live streams covering all of this the
former president arrested and it may
only be the first of many arrests a
report starting to swirl about a
possible second arrest in Georgia later
this month we still have questions about
the federal case but let's not get to
that yet Donald Trump on his way to the
courthouse posting on Truth social truth
essential quote heading to lower
Manhattan the courthouse
seems so surreal wow they are going to
arrest me can't believe this is
happening in America
Maga and listen I agree it was surreal
to so many of us who were watching a
nearly half a million of you stopped by
the live stream where we covered Trump's
uh path down to the courthouse in lower
Manhattan and eventual booking in the
entire thing it truly was surreal we
have video here of Donald Trump's
motorcade arriving at the courthouse
Trump getting out and sort of uh
lumbering waving at one point to the
dozens of supporters that showed up and
then lumbering surrounded by Secret
Service into the courthouse there was
this very unusual situation where there
was a ring of secret service around
Trump and also NYPD and of course New
York uh Courthouse Court officers kind
of managing the uh situation as they as
they often do we then were able to see
video from the 15th floor of Donald
Trump entering the actual uh courtroom
maybe the first time in decades that
Donald Trump actually had to hold the
door for himself and here you see all of
these different rings of security uh
let's take a look at this video
there is Trump entering looking dejected
quite frankly
very briefly there as you see
going into the courtroom these were very
very brief moments Trump then spending
about an hour in the arraignment which
is very unusual legal experts weighing
in that these arraignments even when
there are 34 counts like this usually
there is a a waving of the full reading
of all of these counts this took nearly
an hour and that is not typical for such
an arraignment and we still don't know
exactly what took so long we do know
that the judge did admonish everyone
that he wants uh he I'm sort of
paraphrasing here but that the judge
would like there not to be public
commentary that turns up the heat on
this entire thing that didn't last very
long that I can assure you and then
about an hour later video so let's see
the video going in was 2 28 p.m the
video coming out was 3 24 p.m so almost
a full hour to the minute here is Donald
Trump leaving the courtroom and again a
very very very brief sighting of trump
they're about to come out of the
courtroom let's listen into the Hall
[Music]
okay
And Then There Goes Trump and you see
his lawyer Joe takapina who previously
said Trump did commit a crime when he
was interviewed about this on TV years
ago okay so the judge warning everybody
refrain from statements and social media
posts that could foment unrest and all
of this after there were many messages
critical of the prosecutor before those
certainly didn't stop after and we are
going to get to that so an incredible
moment I mean this really is a historic
moment uh it is unusual it is unique it
is different and then now the focus
starts to become
what is actually going to happen with
these cases what are we actually going
to see happen what are the charges and
what is the maximum possible sentence
let's talk about that next all right so
listen
um there have been a number of reports
with headlines like Donald Trump facing
136 years in prison
many such examples I am not going to
blow smoke
in anyone's body parts in my audience
Donald Trump is not in any real sense
facing 136 years in prison so let's talk
through this entire situation Donald
Trump is accused of 34 felonies and on
paper it is true that individually each
of those felonies could potentially
Garner four years in prison in some
insanely hypothetical sense we have
already seen a number of legal opinions
about this and these 34 felony counts
are all related more or less to the same
act or same scheme you might say and a
number of legal experts and remember
none of this is my opinion I'm just
going by what other legal experts have
said while in some extraordinarily vague
sense you could say Trump is facing 136
years in prison realistically the
maximum he would be facing for all of
these counts would be four and I believe
the real number will be zero now that's
just my opinion and we will get to that
in a moment let's start with an NPR
report called five things to know about
Donald Trump's felony charges what was
Trump charged with
the indictment unsealed includes 34
counts of falsifying business records
with intent to commit another crime and
Aid and conceal the commission thereof
these are class E felonies these are the
lowest classes of felonies in New York
in the state of New York each check
processed by the Trump organization
disguised as a monthly payment for Legal
Services under a retainer agreement is a
count is a count what do we know about
the catch and kill scheme this entire
scheme is based on the idea that Donald
Trump wanted to catch and kill by paying
stories that would be negative to his
reputation this involved a company
called American Media Inc they published
The National Enquirer and we've talked
about different instances of this
there's this first instance involving a
doorman at Trump Tower
the doorman claimed to have a story
about Trump uh fathering a child outside
of marriage that was the first story The
Second Story involved Karen McDougall a
former Playboy Playmate Playboy Playmate
who said she had an affair with Trump
while Trump was married
Ami and their CEO David pecker uh were
involved with Donald Trump and Michael
Cohen in a scheme to pay for her silence
for a hundred and fifty thousand dollars
and the third of three incidents may be
the most well known is the 130 000
payment to adult film actress Stormy
Daniels to suppress her allegations of
unaffair trump has denied all three of
these stories the article which we will
link to in the YouTube description for
this clip talks about what prosecutors
need to prove how Trump is reacting and
what happens next this is maybe the
critical question the judge Merchant set
the next court date as December 4th so
already there will be eight months until
the the next court date Trump's lawyers
are asking for more time which could
already push this into January or even
spring of 2024. now there's two sides to
the delay tactic on the one hand most
many all attorneys in criminal
circumstances will often say
you want to delay as much as you can the
more you delay
the more you are potentially benefiting
yourself as the defendant for a number
of different reasons Witnesses could
forget
or they could die or they could refuse
to be involved or whatever the longer
you wait the weaker the case might
become for the prosecution due to things
that happen with Witnesses evidence
evidence could be lost misplaced tainted
whatever the case may be now there's
always a back there's always a rebuttal
to all of these well it doesn't matter
if the witnesses forget because they've
been deposed and all you have to do is
put up the deposition or uh of evidence
in this particular case is not going to
degrade the way it would in certain
types of violent crimes okay fine but
these are generally the reasons why
attorneys say it's often good to delay
uh prosecutorial priorities could shift
there could be a change in the political
orientation of a prosecutor's office and
you might end up seeing cases dropped or
whatever the case may be so as a general
rule
you often will hear defense attorneys
say you want to delay as much as
possible delay years if you can
the CounterPoint in this particular case
is that from what I've read Trump will
be required to appear in New York for
each stage of this and you could end up
in a situation where this trial or these
proceedings let's say because it may not
go to trial could start to interfere in
the day-to-day of Trump trying to
campaign for president
and if that is the case one could argue
it's actually not great for Trump to
delay until spring of 2024 that's when
he will be locked into a primary battle
and wanting to do rallies and there will
be elections and all these sorts of
things okay so that's where we are now
why do I think Trump will serve no
prison time well I just uh if if again
this is just an opinion people can
disagree with this okay
if you
think that at the tail end of a year or
more of delays
Trump won't take a plea he says he won't
that this will go to trial
that Trump will be found guilty and that
he will be sentenced at what then might
be 77 or 78 or 79 years old depending on
how long this all takes if you think
he's going to be sentenced to prison
then
I think all of that is unlikely but even
if he were I believe that he will be
allowed to serve whatever sentence there
is in home confinement now a couple
people wrote in and said no there are
special facilities for people you know
known like Trump or what
it's just my opinion guys I don't think
Trump will do a single day
as far as this case is concerned what's
coming up of course is Will trump be
charged in Georgia in Fulton County
where the charges would be more serious
and on and on all right so we're going
to follow that let's now go to Trump's
lawyers post arrest press conference
right after Trump was arrested Trump got
directly into a vehicle and went
straight to the airport and flew back to
Florida
his attorneys held a sort of very
strange press conference right outside
the courthouse this is Joe takapina as
well as Trump's other lawyer whose Name
Escapes me at this exact moment in time
but we will find it it didn't go very
well it was just a complete and total
mess the only thing missing was holding
it at Four Seasons total landscaping or
whatever it was called Four Seasons
Landscaping but let's take a listen to a
little bit of this President not use
language he requested that everybody
involved refrain from using languages
inappropriate and by the way that
includes that includes the witnesses the
witnesses for the people
um who were talking Justice concludes
the former president swinging a baseball
bat at the head of the Manhattan D.A
well I don't know where you got that
because
go right ahead I won't address that yes
it is he wants to swing up baseball bat
at anyone's head that was a picture of
him showing off an American-made bat he
was talking about how great American
bats are yeah I mean it's it's certainly
a compilation picture so takapina is
right that the picture was was isolated
it was two different pictures put
together but Trump did post it to truth
Central and we've got the picture up on
the screen it's a picture of Alvin Bragg
side by side with Trump holding a bat
obviously he wasn't actually holding a
bat to Alvin Bragg's head but Trump did
post that to truth social
um let's look at another little bit of
that discussion
language he requested that everybody
involved correct or trained from using
languages inappropriate and by the way
that includes that includes the
witnesses the witnesses for the people
um who are talking just includes the
former president swinging a baseball bat
at the head of the Manhattan D.A well I
don't know where you got that because
first of all first of all first of all
that picture was not him swinging a
baseball bat I mean if you wanted to
start the facts go right ahead I won't
address that yes it is he wasn't swing
up baseball bat at anyone's head that
was a picture of him showing off an
American-made bat but someone else put a
picture of the district attorney next to
him and in an article post that that's
not here
social using language that incites guys
here's what we're going to talk about
today here's what we're going to talk
about today we're going to talk about
and I will say this to you today's
unsealing of this indictment shows that
the rule of law died in this country
because it really no actually the
indictment shows that no one is above
the law and they keep insisting that
this means the rule of the of law died
no what we've learned is not even a
former president is above the law and
that's a great thing to learn while
everyone is not above the law no one's
below it either and if this man's name
was not Donald J Trump there is no
scenario we'd all be here today please
understand that based on these charges
all right so there's takapina and then
we have
um I guess one more clip here uh about
Trump's posts about the judge and the
judge's family messages
address what he posed what he wants to
post or did post but as his attorneys
have you told him to stop posting this
rhetorical questions we can't literally
we can't tell you what we've discussed
so obviously I'm concerned that him he's
continuing to collaborate judge talking
about the judge's wife talking about the
family I mean are you I mean I don't
think the judge was concerned about it
yeah but any other defendant wouldn't
you be like you're not going after the
judge he is not going after the judge he
commented that he thought that there
were some issues that may cause a
conflict that's not going after the
judge he is not threatening the judge he
is not going after the judge he has said
that the deal you may also notice that
someone's holding the leg of a mannequin
over the head of attorney Joe takapina
during this entire thing that's an
important visual component yeah he is
angry because the D.A has brought a case
that is unjustified and so I'm not going
to comment on it you may disagree with
the way he spoke about the process was
he fingerprinted was there was there I
think thank you for your attention all
right so that deciding that this was not
going particularly well for them and
then wrapping it up a wild day in lower
Manhattan let's take a very quick break
next we will talk about the event that
took place at Mar-A-Lago we're going to
hear from Lindsey Graham where there's
so much more Marjorie Taylor green was
run out of Manhattan trying to protest
it was one of the craziest day in
American politics in a long time we will
be back right after this and give you
the rest of the day's news
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
after being arrested the failed former
president Donald Trump drove right to
the airport and flew directly back to
Florida there was an event promoted that
was scheduled for 8 15 PM Eastern last
night where Donald Trump was expected
and believed to speak about the arrest
and potentially it would even be a press
conference where he would take questions
he did not take any questions and Donald
Trump's brains seemed to disintegrate
during the event instead of talking
about yesterday's arrest the charges
against him and his defense he attacked
both the judge and the prosecutor and
kind of ran through his generic list of
grievances seemingly focusing on other
crimes he may have committed very very
strange event so let's start with a
claim that Donald Trump makes that
because he was President any documents
he takes from the White House are by
sort of like automatically Declassified
that's not how it works but again Trump
seems to be focusing on other crimes he
may be arrested for rather than the
crime for which he was arrested
yesterday to give up
but isn't that real obstruction
that's obstruction as President also
you'll notice Trump breathing in a very
strange way just sniffing the entire
thing everything every detail about this
speech was bizarre the right to
declassify documents and the process is
automatic
if I take them with me it's automatic
Declassified
Biden was vice president
he had absolutely no right to declassify
as vice president
he doesn't come under the non-criminal
presidential records act he comes under
the very criminal Federal records act
unfortunately for him but it's not going
to matter because they don't follow the
law which has very severe penalties so
first of all it is not automatic that if
a president just stuffs some documents
into his pants and then leaves that they
are Declassified secondly this was not
why Donald Trump was arrested yesterday
this is a completely different potential
set of charges remember we've got the
georgia-fulton County investigation
that's not what Trump is talking about
you then have the investigation related
to the search warrant served on
Mar-A-Lago that is what Trump is talking
about but those are different possible
crimes rather than the ones for which
Trump was actually arrested yesterday
Trump then attacking the judge saying
the judge hates Trump and the the family
hates Trump the judge's wife and the
judge's kids that every everybody just
hates Trump numbers
not the same place that I know not the
same place that you know
and this is where we are right now I
have a trump-hating judge
with a trump-hating wife and family
whose daughter worked for Kamala Harris
and now receives money from the Biden
Harris campaign and a lot of it
okay
Trump knows exactly what he's doing here
Trump is signaling Trump is spotlighting
Trump is putting a Target on the judge
and the judge's family and it's not like
we don't have evidence that Trump
supporters are willing to become violent
we know that they are I mean of course
there's January 6th you can also go back
further and there was the guy with the I
think it was pipe bombs who was arrested
and what year was it 2017 2018. we know
that there are people in Trump's cult
that will do violence and so when Trump
starts targeting I mean the judge's wife
why is the judge's wife even in Trump's
mouth why why is why is the words the
judge's daughter why is that coming out
of Trump's mouth he knows what he's
doing it's not only the judge that Trump
attacked he also attract attacked the
district attorney Alvin Bragg saying
actually they should arrest and indict
brag
the criminal is the district attorney
because he illegally leaked massive
amounts of grand jury information
for which he should be prosecuted yeah
or at a minimum he should resign there
you go uh of course there is no evidence
that Alvin Bragg has committed any
crimes whatsoever and as we've talked
about before it's Law and Order until
Law and Order is no longer convenient
and then it's just like indict my
political enemies no big deal not a not
a problem Trump then again continuing to
focus on his other possible crimes again
it you know his brain is mush
Trump says that they are the I I
actually struggle to understand this
Trump seems to be suggesting that the
search warrant served at Mar-A-Lago was
illegal and also that they they maybe
want to put Trump to death with the
Espionage it's really hard to follow
this reasonable search and seizure
but they did it anyway because our
Justice
has become Lawless
they're using it now in addition to
everything else to win elections
apparently they're not looking at me
through the view of the non-criminal
presidential records act they came up
with a new one this is a new one
and they're looking at me through the
Espionage Act think of that how does
that sound of 1917 where the penalty
is death
even though that has absolutely nothing
to do with openly taking boxes of
documents and mostly clothing and other
things to my home
which President Obama has done the
bushes it was mostly closed guys the
fact that there were a couple hundred
classified documents that doesn't matter
it was mostly like shirts and Jimmy
Carter's done Ronald Reagan has done
everybody's done in fact
Hillary Clinton got rid of Clinton yeah
uh so anyway I guess he's saying the
search warrant was illegal and that they
are considering I guess or want to give
him the death penalty which is pretty
wacky stuff Trump also claims that he
doesn't need any banks because he has a
lot of cash which of course raises the
question of why Trump is desperately
asking for money if you have so much
money why are you asking your followers
you're a billionaire you're asking
people who make thirty two thousand
dollars a year to donate money to you
but they didn't lose a dollar with us
during this period of time
in fact the banks
we're talking about
made almost 200 million dollars off
Donald Trump
and they like me very much
we never missed a payment never got a
default notice had a great relationship
with all of them sure I don't need Banks
they have a lot of cash a lot of cash
but he's desperately raising money
anywhere that he can CNN in a kind of
funny moment cut away from the speech
and was confused about why Trump isn't
talking about yesterday's arrest which
is sort of the most newsworthy thing
going on
our current recurrence crashing and
we're no longer the former president
speaking tonight at Mar-A-Lago back here
in New York with the panel
um Alyssa I mean this is a reprise of uh
we're waiting for him to talk about what
happened today he finally talked about a
little bit at the end there when we're
cutting out of it I love I love Anderson
Cooper's confusion about what that was
but a reprise of pretty much every
grievance if you were a Republican
who cares about the Republican Party in
the future of the Republican party and
you are watching this tonight realizing
this man now may be more powerful in the
Republican party than he was yesterday
or at least a little bit more so anyway
CNN bravely cutting away but only about
90 seconds before the speech ended and
then lastly here is Trump just abruptly
wrapping up the speech and walking off
oh no did we lose this clip is this clip
glitchy this clips glitchier than
Trump's speech hold on here we go
with all of the
all of that
and with a very dark cloud
over our Beloved Country yeah I have no
doubt nevertheless
that we will make America great again
thank you very much God bless you and
God bless America thank you very much
everybody thank you isn't that great he
spends 30 minutes attacking everyone and
talking about how the country is just
horrible and he wraps up by saying
despite all of the horrible things I've
spent the last 30 minutes talking about
and all the possible crimes I just uh
admitted to things are going to be just
great I'm running and vote for me and
we're going to make America great again
so Trump's brain mayonnaise mayonnaise
or maybe a a bechamel I don't know what
it is but uh certainly something is a
little bit soft up there
um and it was just as crazy earlier in
New York City I want to talk about that
next Marjorie Taylor green the radical
republican congresswoman famously went
into New York City yesterday with a
protest the protest was going to be at
noon in support of trump the then the it
was moved up to 10 30 a.m it was
obviously not going to go very well and
I'm going to show you a couple of clips
of this but Marjorie Taylor green ended
up having to flee her own protest as
heckler's completely shut the entire
thing down here is Marjorie Taylor green
with a megaphone trying to speak to the
crowd uh and yet there are so many
people with whistles that you can't hear
a damn word she's saying it's it's just
it's delightful and remember guys
This is speech this is everyone's speech
she is she has a megaphone and people
have whistles and it's speech versus
speech
[Applause]
down here
by the way there appear to be more
members of the media there than actual
people protesting in support of trump
[Music]
who are doing their jobs
[Applause]
all right so you get it just nobody can
hear what she's saying and it's just all
pathetic now at another point
I am told that the actor Michael
Rappaport who hates Trump
that this is him yelling at Marjorie
Taylor green okay and there is some some
language in this clip I believe that
this is indeed Michael Rappaport there
and just dressing down Marjorie Taylor
green listen to this
[Music]
[Applause]
think hit him with his face hit him with
the space laser and this is as NYPD is
like trying to clear a path for Marjorie
Taylor green and again it's mostly
reporters like it's it most of the
people there are reporters plus Michael
Rapaport screaming at her
[Music]
okay so a lot of screaming at this event
as Marjorie Taylor green had to be
rushed out by I guess security and NYPD
a democratic Congressman Jamal Bowman he
was not amused by Marjorie Taylor
Green's presence there
put your freaking job Marjorie Taylor
green you don't need to be in New York
City talking that nonsense go back to
your District you're not what are you
doing here you're here for politics
you're here cause you want to be VP
you're here for your own fundraising
you're here for your own nonsense yeah
so Jamal Bowman accurately pointing out
what this is all about and then lastly
this is really weird when Marjorie
Taylor green was able to flee to her car
she did an interview with Steve Bannon
who refers to her as as Congressman
for so for some reason I can't really
figure out and she claims that Eric
Adams the mayor of New York City
organized a counter protest against her
check this out uh Congressman Greene
Congressman green
apropos of nothing Steve Bannon refers
to Marjorie Taylor green as Congressman
for from the gender realists very
surprising thing to hear uh Congressman
Greene the mayor of New York Eric Adams
specifically singled you out as a
hooligan that's going to cause a problem
and that you're dangerous and that
you've got to back off and go home your
thoughts ma'am
he didn't just single me out Steve he
threatened me he called me by name and
threatened me the mayor of New York City
I believe is is a thug and he sent his
people here today they had an organized
text uh alert that went out calling what
I would say antifa to bring their
whistles pots and pans all kinds of
instruments to make they brought pots
and pans and they almost started making
a souffle all kinds of noise to drown me
out and drown others here today that are
protesting and here supporting president
Trump the mayor of New York City mayor
Adams owes me an apology I'm an elected
member of Congress I represent hundreds
of thousands of people from Northwest
Georgia but I also represent Americans
all over the country uh that support
anyway you know the really funny thing
was the guy handing out the whistles was
actually reported to be a trump
supporter so like the idea that it was
the left that organized the whistle
protest I I guess a trump supporter
thought that by handing out whistles
they would be able to drown out the
anti-trump protesters across the street
but all it actually did was drown out
Marjorie Taylor green and I'm sure some
anti-trump people gladly accepted
whistles as well so complete and total
chaos on the streets of New York City
and I agree with Jamal Bowman why is
Marjorie Taylor green even there she has
nothing to do with New York City she
says New York City is a terrible place
she says that you know we've got all
this crime in New York City and so on
and so why why bother Marjorie just stay
home or go somewhere else or go to
Mar-A-Lago where she did ultimately end
up later yesterday evening so that was
the big protest organized by Marjorie
Taylor green we'll take a quick break
and be back with so much more
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show all right
let's talk about a couple of other
little side stories that are taking
place here one of the interesting kind
of contrasts or conflicts that has
arisen over the last few days is the
contradiction between
anger that Donald Trump has been
arrested and the claim that this is
really great for Trump well if it's
great for Trump then wouldn't someone be
happy about it but yet all of the magas
are Furious and they say this is the
biggest uh and most injust miscarriage
of the uh justice system if it's great
for Trump then you'd think someone would
be happy about it so this reached a sort
of fever pitch yesterday and I'll just
give you one example although there are
many Newsmax anchor Greg Kelly said that
while under arrest in police custody
Trump looks even more presidential if
you can imagine it you know sit up there
uh visiting with uh with NATO
or on during a state dinner with the
Prime Minister of Japan no no no no no
no
you are at your most presidential while
under arrest in a ratty New York City
courtroom here is Greg Kelly listen to
him say it
president Donald Trump this was
technically in police custody today yeah
going from processing into the
arraignment
and somehow he looks even more
presidential
the brown nosing is giving me cringe
Greg I'm sorry serious I mean we're
talking Eye of the Tiger this is why so
many people are drawn to him he fights
and by the way this is this is all
nonsense right uh I've seen the
indictment and it's a joke it's even
sillier than we thought oh by the way
could you imagine Joe Biden being in
this situation could he survive could he
Thrive Donald Trump just gave an amazing
speech in Mar-A-Lago tonight we'll get
to uh the details in a moment some
highlights but first the Democrats they
wanted this image to be totally
different they wanted the defeated
broken man or under arrest they wanted
somebody like like this guy dsk when he
was arrested I mean that looks pretty
bad or this guy who allegedly I think
killed his parents his father I mean
that's the same table that Donald Trump
was sitting at today or this guy
recently arrested I mean this is what
they thought Donald Trump would look
like instead you know what it looked
like
he was back on The Apprentice there's
nothing damaging about these photos in
fact it's damaging to the people who put
him there okay it's they will be exposed
in fact they already are exposed right
so listen here here's the bottom line
there can be TR there can be truths that
seemingly conflict with each other but
don't so for example
I believe it is true that Trump's arrest
helps Trump in the Republican primary
and it helps him in two ways I do
believe that there are Republicans who
have been kind of disaffected by Trump
who maybe were planning to support
someone else or not vote at all in the
primary and some of them will indeed be
activated by Donald Trump's arrest
because they've been convinced it's
unfair or whatever the case may be so
that will help Trump in the primary the
other way it will help Trump in the
prime areas who on Earth has mentioned
Ron DeSantis in the last week Ron
desantis's name which was very much
front and center in the news is
essentially gone so good for Trump as
far as the primary is concerned if Trump
wins the primary this does not seem to
be good for Trump and in particular if
there is another indictment this is the
exact type of chaos that surrounds Trump
that doesn't get him a single new vote
in the general election and remember
Trump lost by like 8 million votes in
2020. and so if he's going to win in
2024. now yes granted the the difference
in the states that made a difference is
a much smaller number that's always the
case if Trump is going to win in 2024
he needs to find some new votes or the
Democratic turnout needs to be lower
which may be and we'll talk about that
in on a different day I don't believe
that this arrest gets Trump any new
general election votes so these people
are really parodies of themselves this
is the new thing it's great for Trump
trump looked so presidential sitting
there at the defense table uh certainly
in the eye of the beholder to me he
looked angry in the video where he was
entering the courtroom and he looks kind
of dejected while sitting there at the
defense table but everyone is going to
see in it
some degree what they want to see and I
understand that we'll see ultimately
what this does for Donald Trump
Republican senator Lindsey Graham was
again overcome with emotion on
television you might remember last week
he was crying about the Euro pending
arrest of Donald Trump he was on Fox
news last night begging people send
Trump money why you need to send a
billionaire money I don't even
understand but here is Lindsay again oh
this is starting to get a little bit
embarrassing I'm sorry I'm so upset but
please help president Trump if you could
thought Ford five or ten bucks if you
can't afford a dollar fine just pray if
you make 28 grand a year if you can
throw five bucks at this billionaire to
help them please make sure you vote as
early as you can in your state don't
risk anything oh now early voting is
good huh ain't getting any more vote as
soon as you can pray for this country
pray for this President and if you got
any money to give give it
lindsaygram.com it doesn't go to me it
goes to helping this President and
taking back the Senate yep uh then he
continues and he says he set up a
website for Trump it's all crazy three
great Senate pickup opportunities to
give us the Senate back in 2024 three uh
Democrats in deep red states that are up
in 2024 we can take back the Senate and
president Trump can get a second term to
finish out his agenda there's a lot of
love in the streets but love ain't gonna
do it pal they're trying to ruin this
country they're trying to destroy
president Trump tonight I have set up a
website I don't get one damn Penny but I
want you to give money tonight to help
president Trump yeah he's raised eight
million remember to help him what are
you donating to Trump's campaign are you
donating to Trump's primary campaign is
it money for the general is it money
that is for Trump's legal defense like
what what are you donating to Lindsay
ever since this legal garbage started
don't stop now seventy percent of the
money you give tonight goes to help
president Trump 30 percent will help
take back the Senate to help him do what
he's got a chance to pick up three
Senate seats in very red States held by
democrats and I want to wake up after
the election in 2024 with the Republican
house or Republican Senate and Donald
Trump raised his right hand swearing to
be the president of the United States
that we need you are not helpless out
there folks yeah really a dystopian
vision and if you're saying didn't
didn't Lindsay just do this yes here is
Lindsay last week crying on Fox news
about the indictment how do you do it
you take a well
crap and he chop it up
third a pile of crap is duplicious
charging they're trying to smear the guy
they're trying to take cases that nobody
else would take and resurrect them this
is literally legal Voodoo yeah so the
grift is fully back and Lindsay is
trying to take charge of it so there are
of course so many questions here first
of all if Trump's a billionaire why does
he constantly need money for everything
he needs money because of desanctus and
he needs money because of Joe Biden and
he needs money because of Alvin Bragg
and this what's the money for is it for
the campaign legal defense Fund in this
case Lindsay is saying for every dollar
you give through Lindsay's website
Trump gets 70 cents and then 30 cents go
to some kind of General Pool for Senate
re-election campaigns or something like
that this is Lindsay trying to get
credit for bringing money in
fundamentally and as usual Trump likes
his followers to the extent that they're
useful and he went to them and grifted
them after the 2020 election saying oh
we're going to file all these lawsuits
and forensic Audits and recounts and it
all went nowhere nowhere but he grifted
people who statistically don't really
have the money to be giving money to
Trump for this nonsense he grifted them
to the tune of millions tens of millions
I believe it was and now they're trying
to do it again so my thought is save
your money save your money maybe put it
in a savings account maybe get an index
fund account going maybe put it in a 529
if there's a kid who at some point might
need an education and don't give the
money to trump it just doesn't seem like
the most useful use of funds and this is
me advising people who don't like me
but I don't want to see you grifted all
right we have a voicemail number that
number is 2192 David P one of the things
we've heard for a long time now is that
if they can arrest trump it could happen
to you here's a version of that via
voicemail that's kind of tongue-in-cheek
David sir this is Caitlin from Florida
and I am calling you with tears in my
eyes to tell you I am fleeing Florida
because
Trump has been arrested and if he can be
arrested than any of the rest of us can
be arrested so I'm really concerned for
my well-being and the well-being of my
machines you know my car my coffee
machine so I'm just really trying to get
out of here yep but in all seriousness
I'm honeymooning to Montreal in the
summer and I wanted to hear some
suggestions for where I should go to eat
okay for Montreal suggestions maybe call
in I don't want to bore the audience
with that right now but I do want to
address this thing that they've been
saying if they can do this to Trump they
can do this to anyone they do it to
anyone all the time we know that they
can do it to anyone it's not like up
until yesterday we thought wow
once they cross the Rubicon of arresting
a president then they might arrest just
random antibodies now we knew that in
fact the problem all along was there is
this belief that there is a two-tier
justice system and I believe that that
is accurate it's not Republicans and
Democrats it's the wealthy
and everybody else and even yesterday
Donald Trump was able to negotiate no
handcuffs no mug shot it's a private
entrance all these different things so
we already knew it could happen to
anyone the question now of course is
can you actually hold the president
accountable or is this all going to
evaporate and if it does of course the
right will say it's because the charges
were bogus to begin with and we'll have
that discussion but we knew it could
happen to anyone we now know that at
least theoretically even former
presidents aren't Above the Law that's a
good thing to know if you are an
American we have a fantastic bonus show
for you today a Finland joins NATO and
this is a major shift I'll talk about my
time in Finland and there's so many
interesting things to talk about
secondly not only could anti-wokism
backfire on Republicans their obsession
with transgender issues could backfire
as well we'll talk about new polling
that suggests why and yes Marianne
Williamson making polling gains against
Joe Biden many of you said David because
you don't support Marianne you're not
going to cover her polling search I am
going to cover her polling search on
today's bonus show sign up at join
Pacman dot com get instant access and
you can use the coupon code indicted
or you can use the coupon code indicated
it's your choice whichever you prefer
foreign